[ Siren wailing ]
♪♪
-Cassie! Cassie,
I need you at the triage.
-Wait.
O'Neil, will you let me drive?
-What are you talking about?
-I ju-- I don't know,
I just have a weird feeling.
-Well, if you had
a bad experience on the job,
don't let it mess
with your head.
-Cassie, come on!
-Welcome back
to "Late Night," everybody.
We're here with Dakota Johnson.
That was a clip
from "Madame Web."
This is in the larger --
this takes place
in the larger
Spider-Man universe.
-It's actually not
the Spider-Man universe.
-How would I say it?
The Spider-Verse?
-This is -- no, it is
a completely standalone world.
It's Madame Web's world.
-Oh, so I shouldn't use
the word "spider" at all?
-No.
Well, there are spiders.
It's like a little bit Spidey...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-...but it's not
in the Spider-verse.
-Standalone.
Madame Web's world.
-Don't need to worry
about having any
predetermined ideas
or information about --
-No. You don't have to know
anything about anything --
[ Laughter ]
...at all to watch this movie.
-Should I know, like, what
ambulances are? 'Cause, like...
-No.
-Okay.
-You will learn.
-You could learn...
Wow, so this is really, like,
an educational...
-You don't got to know nothing.
It's great for America.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It'd be really --
that'd be the really --
the funniest thing
to put on a poster.
Like, "You don't got
to know nothing."
Yeah, "You don't need to know
nothing about nothing."
-You know nothing?
Come see our movie.
-Uh, you play a paramedic
and a clairvoyant in this film.
-Yes.
-Would you enjoy having --
I mean, again,
I feel like when people
have clairvoyance in films,
that they always have
that thing happen,
where they see terrible...
-Where they go
[Imitates explosion]
-Yeah. And then it's always --
they always jump ahead
to some awful --
-Did you like that?
-That was really good.
-The sound effects?
-Did you do...
Now, you did your own
sound effects in the movie.
-I did.
-Yeah.
-[ Imitates whooshing ]
[ Laughter ]
-The Foley artists were like,
"You know what,
I think we should
just let her do it."
-"We can't do anything
without her."
-"We can't beat it."
That's the best noise
I've ever heard
for someone about to have
a clairvoyant moment.
Would you like to have
the power of clairvoyance?
-No. I'm good.
-I think I'm good, too.
-I feel like
I like being surprised.
-Yeah.
-And I also --
It would be too much
responsibility.
-You strike me as someone --
I believe you like
being surprised,
but do you ever look surprised?
[ Laughter ]
Like, I would feel, if I was
at a surprise party for you
and we all, like, jumped out,
I feel like your expression
might not change at all.
-Let's try. Get down.
-Okay, great.
-Okay.
-Surprise!
Yeah, that's it.
That's exactly what I expected.
[ Applause ]
I just had a surprise party.
Same thing.
I do not surprise.
-You do not surprise?
-I do not surprise.
I walked in and a bunch
of people yelled, "Surprise!"
And my wife said
it was such a drag.
She said,
"You have to try harder."
-What did you do?
-I went, "Oh, okay."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause then I was
doing the math of everything.
Well, everything weird
that had happened
in the previous two hours.
I was like, "Okay."
-Right then?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Not, like, later?
-And they were all like,
"This is such a drag
as he's, like, doing the math."
-Like, wait, "John, Susan.
My...
Oh, and -- oh."
[ Laughs ]
-Well, this means
the world to me.
-Wow! [ Laughs ]
-You are, uh,
you're a millennial.
There are three other actors
in this film who are Gen Z,
and that kind of is one
of the relationships in the film
is how a millennial
would react to Gen Z.
How did you actually like
your Gen Z cast members,
your co-stars?
-I love them.
-Yeah.
-And they annoy me.
[ Laughter ]
-They annoy you
on a generational level?
Like how they're
experiencing life?
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-What's something --
when do you feel --
when did you feel the oldest?
-All the time.
-Yeah.
-Like, every second of the day.
-That's awful. I can't...
-I know.
-It breaks my heart because --
-I'm not that much older
than them.
-But it just -- I think
it's happening so fast now.
These generations
are like turning over.
-[ Imitates Seth ]
It's happening so fast.
-Every day they got a new app!
-They get older and older.
Every day I get older.
It's crazy.
-Hey, we we were co-stars
in something,
which I did not realize
until today.
You were in the final episode
of "The Office."
You were! This is --
and it's kind of crazy because,
like, this is a super -- I mean,
obviously a seminal show.
And you were only
in the final episode.
-I was in the series finale
of "The Office."
You were in that?
-I was in it because
there was a clip where we --
this was in the final episode
of "The Office,"
that there was
a clip of "Weekend Update"
making fun of, um,
Ed Helms' character.
-God, that was honestly
the worst time of my life.
[ Laughter ]
I loved that show so much.
-Of course.
-And they were like,
"Do you want to be
in the series finale?"
And I was like, "Of course,"
thinking that I'd show up
for like half a day,
and I was there for two weeks,
and I'm barely
in the [bleep] show.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I would also imagine --
wasn't everybody super sad?
-They were sad.
And they also, like, there
were weird dynamics
that had been going on
for the last 10 years.
Some people didn't speak
to each other,
and I'm coming in like [Laughs]
"I'm so excited to be here!"
And no one wanted to talk to me.
Nobody gave a [bleep]
and I like --
sorry I'm swearing so much.
I don't --
-No.
-It's 'cause I had a glass
of champagne.
-You know, look, it's
"The [bleep] Office's" fault.
It's not your fault.
-It's their fault.
And I was, like,
in the background
of all of these scenes.
-Oh, right.
That's the whole thing.
-Faxing things,
and I don't know.
-Can I tell you,
I recently watched it
and it was some of the most
believable faxing
I've ever seen.
And a lot of people,
I think, mail it in
when they're in the background
of those shows.
But I was just like,
"Oh, my God!"
It was crazy.
-I was like, well, if I'm here,
then I'm here.
I'm gonna deliver.
-Please come back soon.
It has been too long.
-No.
-I know. I know you won't,
but it's fun.
-I will.
I actually have a little bit
of clairvoyance,
and you're coming back.
-Okay.
-You guys,
that's Dakota Johnson.
-"Madame Web," only in theaters
and IMAX on February 14th.
We'll be right back
with Sheryl Lee Ralph.